okay okay and and what's going on guys
this is Robin and we've got Foust here
for the weekly pool this week and right
now we're just waiting on Benny because
Benny went off to do something and do
some stuff whatever whatever it is that
he's doing he's not here so it's not
victims and we're not help to know about
exact you got people tied up for the
south's
you be quiet but yeah I figured we just
kind of shoot the [ __ ] with you guys for
a little while before we actually went
into this whole thing
but anyway so what's been going on not
much about comics and there is no news
it sucks man like I guess we could do
this into like um South sounds not
feeling good he said he may show up
sometime during the podcast you may not
if he jumps in that's cool if not then
the Nets cool to him so what are my
opinions on Deathstroke see this is the
thing like like every time something
like this happens I'm like alright guys
let's just kind of shoot the [ __ ]
beforehand and it just turns in like a
big Q&A session ya have questions and
you have answers answer them please
bidding is invisible then he is there
you just can't see he gained superpowers
and he's just invisible isn't making
noisy but he could easily meet his
microphone but not he's actually not
making noise he's actually very quiet
yeah I think I think Sal's a cool down
mode after pax but it's all good um
anyway Oh
coming up uh pros there he is
goatee are you slacking it up on me I am
well we're live right now so are you
serious are you blocking it up on me
okay if you were really live I do need
to explain that to something that I hit
a joke
he's the whitest black I have ever met
in my life he was a joke are you kidding
me really life is Rob
not the whitest black guy you've ever
met in your life oh all the yeses are
gonna start rolling in a second me and
fast old whoo I guess fast well people
you were invisible but you had
superpowers I can make you invisible and
nobody can for you just go ahead and
just throw this on there so apparently
I've killed Salomon and replacing him
you are over that case oh no I dropped
my controller activated resident evil I
stood in the back no so guys our
incursions event has ended we are now
we've now settled on who the survivors
are and just like the six one six
universe is now merging with the Ultima
universe we've merged it's super
effective and Marvel explained and
comics Torian and what ended up
happening is TV little house exploded
they're currently battling all of the
all of the members of comic book cast
but since the three members of TV little
house plus the two extra members you
know Tiffany and Danielle so five people
from people that allows don't outweigh
the 30 people the comic book cast has I
don't think they're gonna win this
battle
so we've already selected our
replacement which is fast yep thanks
thank you thank you guys see look here
each heat ray says as a black guy myself
Robbie's very white actually had this
talk a few days ago and I didn't realize
we were alive I make no bones about this
I'm very much white person and I do not
mind it I'm the worst Scottish person
ever
most people don't realize some scottish
until i say it no I thought your
English I'm Tyler he does he thinks I'm
Mexican I'm french-canadian so my people
Harold down from those torrential lands
of Canada very bit no Barrett variant is
not dead variant has become the Beyonder
and in our next secret Wars he'll be the
guy that directs everyone yes he will
and by direct everyone we mean that
you'll probably just start killing
people but you know it's the hair that
won the battle
dude I'm not gonna lie dude I'm jealous
of your hair so I was in the military
for ten years guys I had a buzz cut I've
been trying to think of things to do
with my hair I did the spikes the first
but I'm like oh that's so early 2000s
and now I feel old so I'm trying to be
like trendy but it's not it's not
growing right and it doesn't it does
some weird things and it's just kind of
it's sorry we're gonna go episode I had
a flashback okay okay so alright so so
yesterday yesterday I think it was
Minnie and me and Vinny were talking and
then he had this really really good idea
about what it was that Marvel is doing
I'm live reasonably was Marvel answering
DC or DC answering Marvel about Marvel
releasing like all these stories in DC
releasing like 40 stories during
conversions like to issue stories but I
can't remember which one did you say was
what no I said basically what it looks
like okay so here's my theory on the
whole converging Secret Wars thing
basically my theory is that Marvel has
had this in the tank for four years DC
has had this in the tank before years
but Marvel had it planned DC was like
we're gonna do something with the
multiverse and maybe a crisis we don't
know and Marvel was like stupid Wars
everyone's gonna fight and indie Cindy
sees like oh you're doing that in May in
April we've got a convergence and and so
the statement is it found Stephen knows
about this is that DC is supposedly kind
of throwing continuity out the window
they're gonna maintain the new video to
continuity but what they're what we're
getting is they apparently just want to
keep doing things like the
with one series they want to keep doing
things like these weird what-if
storylines and they just they don't want
to worry about like the Superman the
fact that Superman unchained and super
owed the new power kind of like are
happening coinciding Lee they want to
get rid of those problems some stories
will just be standalone stories that
aren't they don't care if they go into
the main stuff um and it looks like
Marvel is going in that same direction
because it gets rid of the restrictions
that Marvel has the problem is DC will
just tell a good story while Marvel will
try their best and delays storylines
so that all the timelines line up yeah
oh we can't do this big story that
involves spider-man yet because he's
tied up in spider-verse DC would have
just been like we'll do them both and
you can guess what came first if it was
something like that or what but I think
that makes sense because like Marvel
said that post like this this new
battleworld is going to be the new
Marvel Universe post secret Wars but I
don't understand why like I don't
understand why you would have a universe
that revolves around kill Raven that was
a stupid story I don't understand why
you would have a universe that is like a
continuation of like future imperfect
and things like that I don't understand
why some of those things would continue
going so I think that what they're gonna
do is they're they're gonna have their
big battle world they're gonna have all
these universes and then out of these
universes will come like their whole I
guess what's left like that will be the
universe going forward after that but I
don't know I mean either way I don't
what do you think what this whole thing
Faust we were talking about this before
the show so I mean my whole thing of DC
situation is that like the main
attraction for me with the DC universes
is this extended into leading continuity
and for them to kind of just say hey
we're getting rid of that it's just a
bit like well there goes the biggest
poll for me as much as I do love the
characters and everything around that
sort of continuity I loved the fact that
it was all connected I could kind of
figure out Oh Harley Quinn is happening
after Suicide Squad right that makes
sense yeah but now it's just kind of
gonna be a bit like I mean these are
good stories but this character wouldn't
there I think you're trying to avoid
right now is currently we have like five
Batman books and they like to try and
pretend they're all happening at the
same time and I made a joke along
ago that between 7:00 to 9:00 p.m.
that's Batman and Robin because that's
before bit Damian's bedtime then you
know between between 9 and 11 that's
Detective Comics because that's what
Batman first goes off on his own he's
all by himself between 11:00 and 1:00
that's the Batman main story because
because you got to think everyone on
their own side at their own Batman
stories Nightwing Red Hood they're busy
doing their own thing for the early
parts the hours and it seems in the main
Batman book is when they all pop in you
know so that would have to be in the
middle of the night whatever was done
with their other storylines you know and
then it's like one two like three that's
where Batman Superman happens so you
know he like he kind of you know after
the one o'clock if he goes and hangs out
with Superman because super is waking up
it's early in the morning that's kind of
Kryptonians they don't sleep past
midnight it's a thing they do I'm making
this up as I go so that that's that's
what they all hang out until about 3
a.m. then between 3 a.m. until you know
the middle of the next day
that's Justice League because if you
notice Justice League always seems to
take place during the day so of course
that would be early morning because
that's also when Aquaman wakes up you
know fish they sleep between midnight to
6:00 a.m. so another random made-up fact
I just threw out there and Batman just
feels his life on Red Bull coffee no no
no between between at like when everyone
goes to get lunch at noon he power naps
and then he's recharged and he goes
right back to that Justice League battle
um any other cameos that he makes like
when he just showed up in Green Arrow
that happens during the day also now I
know in the book green era it looks like
it's happening at night it's not because
during the night he's already
preoccupied so it must have happened
during the day it was just a very shaded
area
I really hope someone illustrates this
the nature of fish sleep is an area of
active research while fish do not sleep
in the same way that land mammals sleep
most fish do rest research shows a fish
may reduce their activity and metabolism
while remaining alert to danger some
fish float in place some wedge
themselves another well I just talked
about how they sleep so they don't know
that's because I just did a list on sea
creatures
you notice that there's a fish that has
his eyeballs free-floating in his head
and it just looks or ever it needs to
really I just his skull is also
see-through it's like completely
see-through so like they're just like
just like they're always looking up but
he can look him down or around sideways
and the see is [ __ ] weird did you see
that there was a video about a grouper
that ate of four foot long shark while
they were fishing it like they were
reeling it in and then the screw perdus
comes out of nowhere and just eats it
and people were like I hate the ocean
and this one guy's like professional
fisherman here or no he was said oh he
was a sailor he was like sharks are one
thing he's like groupers are a whole
different beast but but no I don't know
I mean I think that here here so here's
here's one of the things that I'm kind
of worried about with what DC's gonna do
post convergence I mean they're shaking
their lineup they're changing some
things up but the question is does it
really even need to happen like if DC
had the new 52 they launched the new 52
and they said okay gosh this is going to
be the continuity going forward and this
is going to be the continuity after
conversions it's just going to be some
other sources so what was the point of
convergence in the first place I mean
why did it I mean it's not as though
they're getting rid of a new 52
continuity entirely like they're keeping
it in sales it's strictly a marketing
standpoint yeah exactly
because what's discovered and even
Marmol know is just when you do a big
event or you restart the universe it
boosts your sales so for most Seager
orsa as a restarting in the universe
promote conversions of restarting at the
universe I mean heck every crisis was
promoted as a restarting of the universe
and final crisis didn't restart [ __ ]
just kept going to crisis and final
crisis felt like the same [ __ ] event
from so it's it's like but those gave
them views it's gonna restart the event
we're gonna send Batman through time see
I don't like I mean I understand see
this this is kind of win in a perfect
world do you see one of you in done
conversions like there would've been any
need for it all they would have said is
okay like we're just gonna
characters and different stories
whatever and it would have been fun DC
or I'm sorry Marvel needed like a new 52
Marvel needed to just be like okay guys
this is your zero just wipe the slate
clean and start over and that's what I
would have done going forward if I ruled
the world but I don't so I don't know
and see Marvel is even more confusing
with what they're gonna do
posts Secret Wars like we don't know
exactly how the universe is gonna look I
mean they may destroy some stuff
everything shakes up and then after it's
all said and done and we look inside and
see what's going on there may be you
know like 15 different realities as
opposed to like 50 when the seeker wars
you know if it initially started I don't
know but either way like it is it's a
convoluted mess like looking at it
leading up like it's just a total
nightmare you know it's not looking in
but I think that once we get into it
it'll probably become a whole lot easier
but until then like my god like they
have made it ridiculous they're doing it
on purpose to them in a matter of fact
you and I were talking about it
yesterday and my original plan going out
was I would have a new video for
convergence secret wars every day but
that's 40 videos just for convergence in
a month yeah that's just converted it's
now trying to do the 30 or so for Secret
Wars guys let me ask let's ask the
audience would you enjoy seventy plus
videos for me and what comics explained
for an entire month
seventy videos tens of these all the
videos in a day yeah like I'm model
that'd be nuts I'll tell you right now
happy at the end of that I'm going back
on break oh what's that in ship and I'm
going to the Hawaii for a week do you
know there's only 24 hours in a day
right just making sure you're okay
I just read comics I mean it's it would
be coming it would be absolutely crazy I
mean one one video a day that's that's
forty days straight of DC's convergence
alright and that's that's assuming you
see the problem with that is that's
assuming they release like one right
after the other like they have one they
have a story for us to do every single
day that may not be the case I mean
they're gonna be to issue stories but
you have a pretty empty but may is when
everything's gonna come out at the same
time so I think
think Secret Wars is to issue stories
converges will be ending that whole
month so it's like ten ending bang
story's ending a month a week so you
have to tend to do every week like just
ten videos I don't know I mean you need
to do a history of every one of the
stories every day
oh god I mean I mean like and that's the
problem with like with Secret Wars
because they say okay guys like here's
Secret Wars we don't know how long the
issues are gonna be we know the DC is
doing two issues per 4040 release for a
42 topic release or whatever it is
alright what we don't know is with
Marvel are they gonna do the same thing
like is feature imperfect going to be
two issues or is it going to be like
five issues or something like that like
that's yeah that's a lot of crap to cram
in I think that if DC says we're gonna
do 40
you know let's say realities for the
sake of discussion 40 stories and each
of those stories is going to be two
issues alone that's simple for DC we're
like okay cool we can just you know
cover that and you know done done
if mall is like well like future and
purpose gonna be five issues and then
you know Days of Future past is gonna be
your I guess your future path is gonna
be like two three maybe four issues and
it's just like oh my god and knowing
Marvel they'll probably do that you know
what I can already see it's gonna happen
knowing Marvel like it's gonna be all
over the place but initially they'll all
be they'll all be one issue and like Lex
spider-gwen and if it does well there
will be a 10 issue follow up immediately
shoehorned in there just crammed in
there I don't know I mean that's god
that's confusing that's gonna be a
nightmare regardless of how it turns out
it's gonna be absolutely insane and you
know if Kamala's book does really well
they're gonna somehow shoehorn a Young
Avengers runaway title in there as well
because in it every [ __ ] event where
there's some interest around teen heroes
they suddenly come out with oh we're
doing young adventures and Runaways too
didn't they already announced the return
of runaway someone was saying that I had
heard something announce the return of
Runaways and nobody here is immoral look
your facial expressions are the best
bounce
when did they announce face it was
supposed to be supposed to be announced
today like they're supposed to have like
a section for a battleworld that's
supposed to feature the like none of its
like I'd be like The Runaways Title I
Runaways number one but it supposed to
bring the Runaways back into the Marvel
landscape which I don't care I've never
cared about The Runaways like they were
never important use my anime [ __ ]
into my comic books and I love it you
know with The Runaways are the children
of characters that people loved as a way
to try to see if people would like the
idea of the children of villains and it
was kind of dumb I thought like just
overall you think it was a dumb idea I
think yeah if he was done not only that
Fauss I think people who like The
Runaways are dumb too I'm a [ __ ]
look like anime and it wasn't they
weren't the worst stories ever told it's
just I always kind of felt like you know
The Runaways had their decent run they
had a recent time by the time we got
around to the point when the Runaways
serve any real purpose for me in terms
of comic books that was getting into
Civil War stuff like that and The
Runaways were just kind of shoved in
there like hey Jon they were just kind
of shoved in there and and I was like
why are we talking about The Runaways
being in San Francisco when they're not
really having anything to do with the
Registration Act there's kind of like
man guys like this kind of sucks like
yeah we're shopping and enjoying life
but you know the registration that kind
of sucks too I didn't really care about
that much yeah
I will admit like that was a huge missed
opportunity for the Young Avengers like
I would have preferred just a Young
Avengers title in civil war as opposed
to like a young event just run away
title because it just had nothing to do
with anything and the then Hulk Ling
suddenly became important at the last
minute of civil wars like well as the
build-up wells the build-up to that
yes that's what I didn't get like they
they had this awesome idea
I mean having having the Young Avengers
was a chance to give them legitimacy in
civil war and instead all that happens
is the Young Avengers are taken by
Shield Forces Captain America's first
strike is to free the unev engines and
then they just don't do anything for the
rest of civil war it sucked I mean I
love Marvel and DC but they just did a
lot of the same kind of like they'll set
up stuff that doesn't matter and now
that wasn't like spider-verse just today
there's so many red herring plot lines
in that one yeah spider-verse I'm so
getting over that spider woman's or
anything cancelled only did that
surprise anybody it surprised me because
I bet some friends have just lost 50
pounds oh really
I bet that would at least ten issues you
bet money on the success of Spider Woman
like that's a big that's crazy
cuz I like the character just I've never
in a bet money on her again a woman has
never like she's never gained any real
ground in popularity with with with
Marvel Comics I mean she did in the
early days when she first popped up
people were like oh hey like a female
spider-man this is kind of intriguing
and then within 10 issues people were
just kind of like meh whatever and
nobody really cared about and her
character just never recovered like when
they released and when they introduced a
Julia carpenter I think and Secret Wars
people were just like why is she here
and and here's literally the explanation
Marvel gave when Julia carpenter showed
up and Secret Wars like the characters
asked like how did you get here like you
weren't here with us so how are you here
and she was like well when the Beyonder
made battleworld like he tore out chunks
of like different planets and one of
them happened to be like denver from the
planet earth and I was there when that
happened and that's why I'm here now and
people were like that was the
explanation with Jessica drew is she's
never I mean she's got a lot of
character development but she's never
got any really like any she's always
been like check it out we got a really
skin
girl and she's got a really skin turn
out but this is important they made fun
of in the latest issue her outfit and
she's just Spider Woman that's that's it
like as many times they tried to make
irrelevant like you said they never did
I mean even in the most recent Avengers
Assemble run she had like a core role
yeah and did nothing
yeah she has so because when I think of
her I always tend to have a bit of a
nostalgic woman think of her first run
where her book was just [ __ ] weird
but we I will admit like in like the
past so 10 20 years she has just
consistently been my tits are too big
for this comic I mean yeah like it was
the same thing with like like Emma Frost
was a good example like every time you
ever saw him with frost in the comics
her boobs are just hanging out and there
was his hilarious across like her boobs
away yeah put your boobs away that was
the name of this article of this chick
road where she was just like why do our
boobs have to hang out all the time and
I was like because boys love that and
they're gonna go by the comics or the
x-men to see it like that's why it's not
rocket science but um but I don't know I
mean like I said you know like just
looking at some of the stories that
Marvel is doing like is for extinction
the Explorer sanction is was Grant
Morrison's quick run in x-men where he
had Cassandra Nova kill off 16 million
mutants and leave Genosha in a state of
total desolation that was it like
there's nothing to continue from there
and so I don't know if they're gonna
rewrite that story and they're gonna
come back and say okay now this is a
universe in and of itself I mean I don't
understand how you would bring that into
seeger wars the only way I can think of
it if you were gonna rewrite it that's
what it is with a lot of those stories
like like Planet Hulk I mean these
aren't stories that branched off to
create what if stories they're just
self-contained stories there's no what
if Cassandra Nova didn't destroy Genosha
that doesn't exist and nobody would read
it if it did and so I have no idea where
they're gonna go with that entire
concept but regardless of what they do I
am I am incredibly curious to see what
happens
I'm just reading the comments here and
there all quoting Faust yes my tits are
too big super effective to kick mega
boobs the whole pockets talking about
boobs and calm I mean you know like you
just talk about boobs so I guess I love
all the comments at the moment it just
boobs
we're Sal and pals said boobs ever loved
Emma Frost's boobs ever from us red
boobs okay moving on the talk about
degenerated like how can whatever we
don't have a core topic to talk about
like it boils down to haggis or Emma
Frost boobs I don't
oh yeah haggis man like okay no I have
its topic though cuz someone brought it
up and only we've ever discussed it okay
Deadpool's die we have not talked about
that because the story hasn't been
released yet no but its leading up to it
he's the sad clown and they keep messing
with them I I think I'm the only one
that reads current Deadpool but right
now pretty much like he's messing his
life up but see like I don't even know
is is gonna fit in either because
remember during circuit wars are gonna
have Deadpool secret secret ward
wait what yeah maybe that's how he dies
he dies do go to the secret secret boy I
guess like that's what they're calling
it like they were they were trying to
figure out what they were gonna do with
Deadpool they were like do we get him
into Secret Wars and people were like
nope because we saw the Deadpool Corps
and Deadpool vs Deadpool like we know
all the Deadpool's that are out there
and like most all of them died when they
were killed by by evil Deadpool but now
they're saying like during Secret Wars
Deadpool is gonna have his own event
called Deadpool secret secret war so I
don't know what the hell is going on
there
I mean following up with Deadpool and I
know Faust is a huge deadpool fan and so
am I gonna have to prime it but I've
been following it for awhile and they
just out of the blue said yeah we're
gonna kill him but the fans are gonna
love it it's a part of the story I don't
think he's really going to die die like
no isn't it isn't it dated to happen in
April first or something yeah like like
they're saying how he's gonna die and
they've been setting up for a while
which they have they gave him a wife
which died they gave him a kid which
he's trying to take care of they're
trying to give him like a stable life
he's married to Dracula's Bride right
now it's just he's not supposed to be
happy they're trying to give him a
stable life he's married to Dracula's
Bride just receive that alone but what
I'm saying is like their key promoting
Deadpool's gonna die and then like I was
gonna be great it's for the story it's
the it's the eventualities to what we've
been doing to him and I'm like yeah you
might kill him but no one has ever said
death was gonna stay dead they've killed
the dead bull before at the end of the
last run the jokes he jokey run he died
he like died and we discovered that he
had like this little sliver of healing
factor left so he would come back in a
few months
yeah but he was killed at the end of
that so that's kind of where I think
we're going with a death the Dead Pool I
think it's gonna go in a direction of
he's gonna die he is but we all know
Deadpool can't die die like permanently
so Jimmy Feb my most comic book
characters can't die I know they don't
come back or or he is gonna die and he's
just gonna come back and Secret Wars a
different universe Deadpool cuz yeah
most of the Deadpool Corps did kill off
Deadpool's but there are a bunch of
remaining you know and there's no
there's no guarantee that that was all
of them so it could because I mean we're
all expecting Wolverine to come back
following the secret wars with a new
universe or whatever and maybe Deadpool
just gonna die just before it and they
were like ah [ __ ] it we'll just kill him
off right before the event happens it'll
come back at the event yeah I mean most
secret was I'm expecting Wolverine to be
back Cyclops back to normal
Jean Grey back we mean I acted so bad I
am so tired of accomplished I save you
back he's back now kind of is he I mean
behind an x-men comics i oh the last
issue to resolve the latest thing
without revealing the whole plot they
went back in time grabbed a young
compressor Xavier brought him back to
the present and then so he was there
doing stuff and they brought him back to
his time period and he's supposed to
wipe his own memories out but like I
don't think he's going to think yeah
okay so it kinda you have the knowledge
of the future but here I trust you to
just forget all that
that's you know somebody said Jim Lee's
dead oh no I might actually read a story
about Deadpool by Jim Lee but no I don't
know I mean Deadpool I think we can all
pretty much agree it's probably Marvel's
most popular character I mean I don't
know why he wouldn't be like anything
like anything Deadpool number one is
going to sell more than anything else
because people are just like oh god I
knew Deadpool story and they're gonna
run out and they're gonna buy it
yeah but it would be an incredibly
stupid move even for Marvel to kill off
their most popular character Wolverine
it was time for him to die like
everybody knew it was time for Wolverine
to go even the most die-hard Wolverine
fans like okay guys look like it's time
to go just get rid of him but Deadpool I
mean he's a great break from the
monotony of Marvel Comics and so to me
it made perfect sense that if they were
gonna kill him off they would have to
bring him back and so maybe that's what
they're gonna do but the problem with
Deadpool is I don't think Deadpool
story's been completely done he's been
around for a while and everyone has
talked about him but majority of the
time his story is look at how goofy he
can be and like there's been no
development there's nothing else
he's just the goofy guy who flipped
sides haha and only recently have you
really started to get development on his
character which we haven't had since
cable Deadpool like yeah I think that's
one of the reasons why I kind of just
like Deadpool because there's a way to
progress a character along with showing
how funny they can be and like I'm a
comedy right to myself so every time I
read it I'm like you know I can admit
like I can see why people would find
this funny but where's the character
decide that that that's why I don't like
that foetal well that's why I like a lot
of people you know who don't like that
people will have your same opinion
they'll say look this is not necessarily
the comedy of Deadpool that's bad it's
the fact that this Deadpool is the same
Deadpool since Joe Kelly's run in like
1990 whatever it was 1995 or 96 or
something like that like it's been the
same character this whole time he's
never changed you know what I agree
doing that I 100
because even Wolverine adapted and
changed he became more caring he got to
run a school his character developed and
evolved and while he did show up in
every comic book known to mankind he
still developed and evolved and Deadpool
has only recently started to get real
character again yeah so people are
asking where cable is I don't know if
the last I knew about cable he had gone
into the future with hope summers too in
order to raise her and then I think he
died and then that's it I don't remember
a word Deadpool or where cable is or
what cables been doing I have does
anyone know or care he came back to the
past
any Marvel now he hopes that was found
him once and he was like I'm watching
over you might as well be he's just like
kind of stalker Lee watching his adopted
daughter from a distance well but see
this is why I say mobile newsroom okay
name me character's name give give me
ten characters in Marvel Comics or even
then give me five characters in Marvel
Comics that have been around since their
entire count like when their continuity
first started before the 90s all right
that have been around since the 1990s
and who are better now than they were
then I'm not a single person you you
can't you there's there's no argument
there some people may say well I think
our you know the better person isn't
knowable because nobody like richard
writer this thing's gonna have like a 75
to 25% dislike to like ratio if you have
to pick richard rider or nova who or Sam
Alexander who are you going with but
that's that's the problem that Marvel
has like that's why new 52 was such a
great idea like Marvel has
like people are just burned out on the
same old [ __ ] like that's just the way
it is like like spider-man now with
spider-man 20 years ago sure the stories
are a little bit different and they try
to shake things up with one more day
Straczynski was like hey look guys like
they told me to do that like you know
don't blame me you know and and it just
all kind of went to the tank like the
Fantastic Four is the same old thing and
so on and so forth people want news
stuff and that's what they try to do
with like Cyclops in the x-men they're
like let's make Cyclops a dick and
people were just like no no this is
absolute garbage it was there was a
comment in here actually real quick
about that but we just we can go right
back to what you're saying um but they
did bring up one thing I forgot Rick
Remender is Deadpool in x-force he had a
lot of growth where he got the no Kid
apocalypse and stuff yes he did that was
cool because Richard riders horrible
guys why do you think they killed him in
the guardians of the galaxy in like a
one-page oh no my name is made of haggis
but that's that's the problem that
Marvel has is it's it's the same old
same old that's that's the problem like
that I think that's why a lot of people
are looking at secret Wars and they're
saying like okay you know but at the
same time they're a little hesitant to
because they're like once this is all
over they're not rebooting anything
they're not giving us new characters
they're just continuing on with what
they have and people are just kind of
like all right well no they're not
continuing on they are rebooting like
there there is a definitive Lee said
they are rebooting but you are right
we're not getting like new people we're
not getting new super we're not getting
a new Avengers with all new people in it
no it'll it'll be Avengers with Captain
America and Iron Man it'll probably be
closer to the movie Avengers now you
know yeah all the characters gonna start
matching their movie counterparts we all
know that's coming yeah I mean I always
say if they really wanted to do the evil
Cyclops thing or just have a cool x-men
member that everyone recognizes become
evil they should have done it with one
eye sort of like the lesser ones like
robe or something cuz yeah she started
out as evil make her evil again but this
time make a [ __ ] mentally damage from
the Phoenix and then see what [ __ ]
happens that would have been interesting
but
Cyclops is just a bit like well give him
a hook and he could be a pirate
the problem is with evil Cyclops and I
think this is where the issue with evil
Cyclops has come in is he's not really
evil it feel it felt to me like I like
okay we're gonna change things up we're
gonna make Cyclops kind of a bad guy but
we don't want to go full-on bad guy so
he's going with his direction and his
purpose but we don't want to full-on
make him like evil because then we'll
get too much hate so that's what felt
like to me so it's like oh he's evil and
he's against everything everyone
believes but he's following what he
thinks Professor Xavier is philosophy is
you know that what the it's funny
because even in the latest uncanny x-men
that's how it ended like the
time-traveling girl shows up and she
goes a sec up and she was like fix your
[ __ ] like this basically what she says
he's like excuse me
she's like fixed it or I'm going to wipe
you from existence and he's like what
are you talking about he said you can't
talk to me like that she's like you're
gonna fix it or I'm going to wipe you
from existence it she's like is that a
threat she's like yes fix your [ __ ] I
mean wow somebody has a really good
question do we think that they're gonna
be killing off the Incredible Hulk and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe because
he's not listed for civil war well
there's no other guys who want to list
for something like like Thor's not
listed for civil war I don't think and
there's a handful of people who aren't
listed for civil war but a hoax
expensive that's why that's yeah he's
very expensive that's why you get such
little screen time and it's also why
they've debated not doing another movie
with him oh why he's not on any it has
nothing to do with the fact that the
last Hulk movie was horrible because it
nurser one no no but I mean that movie
was not terrible no I'm saying no I like
the Edward Norton one but a lot of
people like to just oh it's not really
in the cinematic universe that kind of
an attitude yeah and what I'm saying
though is it has nothing to do with that
cuz a lot of people like oh they're
delaying on Hulk because last one was so
bad they want to separate no it's
because doing a Hulk movie you either
have a very boring Bruce Banner story
that no one's really gonna watch or you
spend an arm and a leg to get the Hulk
in there or you just do a Captain
America story I mean like that's true I
mean that's that's
really all there is to it I mean you got
a 10-foot tall green guy he's made
completely out of special effects right
and you have to do massive destruction
everywhere he goes you know you came to
set big tall green guy with special
effects just standing there it's not I
mean how much screen I didn't even get
in Avengers like it was actually like
they've removed him almost immediately
so he wouldn't they wouldn't have to use
him
well it wasn't until halfway through
that he turned into the Hulk I said I
mean like it was just remotes in the
whole equation yeah yeah I don't know um
but that is kind of surely they're gonna
kill him off but I mean I think it's
gonna be it'll be interesting to see how
that civil war story unfolds boom less
but that's but see that's that's what
I'm and I guess the same kind of thing
you know going back to what we were
saying before the same thing could be
applied to DC in the sense that with the
new 52 continuity like they're
continuing a lot of the characters but
the more I read DC Comics especially
with the new 52 the more I'm actually
leaning a little more towards DC than
Marvel and I know people are gonna give
me [ __ ] about that
okay like look at the new inhuman run in
Marvel Comics alright like it's done
like the new inhuman run is that okay
here's here's the new inhuman run summed
up in like 10 seconds alright black
bolts been missing due to an event that
has something to do with the incursions
we don't know what it is we don't find
out until halfway through that he was
taken by Maximus the mad he was putting
her mind control that he was basically
sitting like a mile away from new
Attilan while I guess Medusa was dealing
with having people trying to usurp her
throne while all this is going on the
Inhumans are starting to wake up as a
result of the Terrigen mists and so
basically we're dealing with like
teenagers learning how to be Inhumans
this is and this is like the x-men
basically is what yeah I get that but
what I'm saying is I think it's I think
it has two thumbs up first off this is
the whole running theory that they can't
get the x-men so they trying to make new
x-men basically right but I think the
second factor is they've tarnished the
name of the x-men amongst comic book
fans most of us look at it as huh supid
freaking Cyclops and you kill Wolverine
and Professor X is dead and rogue is now
some teacher girl who's like no issues
at all and where the [ __ ] is gambit does
anyone even know like make hole
to be honest let's be honest it hasn't
done anything since the 90s so when
people tell me gambits my favorite
member of the x-men I always just go
when did you stop reading comics no the
last important thing that gambit did was
like like astonishing no it was a son it
was a x-men vol 2 issue 180 something
when apocalypse out here was like hey
guys I know that like the entire
population of mutants has been decimated
there's only like a handful of you left
but like if you guys drink my blood
you'll get powers and then you'll rise
to prominence again and gambits like
i'll be a horseman of apocalypse and so
apocalypse is like welcome on board and
gambits like cool he subjects them to
look back good to have you buddy we're
not seen we're like Voldemort hugs
Malfoy you know and in camp it's like
all right like I'm a Horsemen of
Apocalypse Now and then like at the very
end of the whole thing
gambit and Ozymandias like they turn on
apocalypse and apocalypse like what are
you doing a gambits like I've been
playing you the whole time
I was just pretending to be a horseman
so I could defeat you and I'm like yes
here's the kicker you guys are all like
isn't anything important I did all of
you forget that he had a really awesome
comic run of like 12h news like two
years ago it was a secret agent and he's
like really good yeah but you are right
and I think what they're doing with that
is they tarnish the name so much that
they're doing this
remember that x1 for the 90s that you
all love and you actually in liked we're
trying that again with this comic they
tried it with all new x-men and they
made it way too convoluted way too fast
so no one cares anymore so they try and
get one more time and I think that's the
point of the Inhumans while they're
trying to revive the x-men as a pro
actually that sells comics they're
trying to they're gonna give you
Inhumans they're gonna make them the new
x-men yeah this will show up pull his
hood off reveal that he's bald and be
like actually I can talk and I'm
telepathic and I'm crippled I won't rest
until Julia gets her powers back and
dazzla gets her own comic again I don't
understand okay we talked about this
like you were gone at the time bidding
me and Faust talked about this and I
don't understand Foust is loved for
Dazzler or Jubilee one
make fireworks and the other can make
less impressive fireworks no no people
don't you please power jubilee can make
explosions and she can control how big
they are
if she wanted to she could make an
atomic size explosion of her personality
that that was a speculation at the hands
of Emma Frost who said she has the
potential to detonate matter on a
subatomic level she never did
she made fireworks and she listened to
fireworks this was a really cool person
for the 4th of July
yeah but if you're ever as Skrillex
concert and Jubilee when the bass jobs
Jubilee be like you know who my favorite
x-men of all time is because he doesn't
exist outside of like a very small
medius morph most useless
I mean he was a cool character until
they killed him thanks to you Faust I
just had these images of the x-men on
the back of a Skrillex concert and just
Jubilee like like Marvel if you're
watching this x-men 92 all right I want
to see early nineties dubstep and I want
to see Jubilee like Raven her ass off
well I'm gonna laugh about is it they
try making do really interesting and
have her make servic tommix subatomic
explosions in x-men night into I'm gonna
be like I told everyone
Jubilees [ __ ] interesting is a
vampire people like Rob you turned your
back on Marvel hey guys you see you know
I know Rob turned his back on Marvel but
uh fast and I are launching the real
Marvel explain and
that was kill me don't worry guys it'll
be nothing but marvel explanations that
we're gonna talk about it for an hour at
a time
posture you've got time yeah like you
know two minutes a day
well you're not utilizing that to the
best of its potential so I don't need to
sleep
seriously yeah just have the shocking
realization that your comics explained
imagine that comic six-lane imagine it's
it's almost as if like I explained more
than just Marvel Comics it's crazy to be
fair Elyse jojomo name is something to -
Cummings mine's cool it's super
effective and that's a [ __ ] Pokemon
reference I love how you throw those
things in there like this character did
this and the writer did this because and
it's super effective I think it'll be a
hit he didn't turn his back people
people are like standing up for me like
no no you have to believe what I love
about this though is especially in this
this is is Rob you have white knights
like like make the girl - the hot girls
that get the white yes I am the maiden
of my white knights I am the damsel in
distress and then you're gonna be put
onto a white horse and have a long
blonde wig on covering your private bits
the car
Kenny puts on the whole dress and he's
the fairy the magical princess god man
it would be like that scene from
tombstone or what's-her-name's riding
the horse did you guys ever see that
there was there's a scene where Kurt
Russell and the trigger riding the horse
and they go to turn a corner and you
could see like the third leg because
she's supposed to be riding saddle side
but she's got both legs hanging over so
you can see both her legs on the side
and the third letter
hanging off it looks terrible yeah I was
just referencing Lady Godiva oh well the
record guys who are joining us late um
it just you want to know what the
today's topic is there really isn't one
we're just talking about comic books in
general nothing's really happened we're
just kind of waiting for convergence and
Secret Wars to start up and and for
those of you who are asking stylistic
today we did not kill him what do I
think about age of Ultron vs. mom okay
that's a really good one guys what
Marvel Zombies what age of one would
know what DC said like I went remember
what Marvel said is I'm went back and
watched her thing and they said that the
age of Ultron versus the Marvel Zombies
are going to be like two opposite like
they're gonna be two different universes
but I assume they're gonna come into
conflict at some point along the line
but that introduces a cool concept what
would happen like could anything happen
to Ultron I mean he's just a source of
energy in metal so could they what if he
becomes a zombie Ultron and now has the
ability to just turn everyone into
zombie Ultron's see that'll be my
question like just make zombie Ultron's
look how badass would that be just like
zombie electrons flying around we could
do it Sambi electrons I mean that'd be
pretty powerful make it happen princess
Kenny see everyone knows what I was
talking about
princess Kimmy that's princess Kenny Oh
if you is never seen so many let's place
at okay
and never gets old game like for the n64
or the stick of truth no stick of truth
dude that game was so much better than
everyone thought it was gonna be I
haven't played it like I've never played
it and this is why you fail at life Rob
I guess man I guess but I mean that in a
loving way first turning you back home
Marvel now you haven't plate Sticka
truth what do you do with your time Rob
I just sit around reading comics and
stuff and it's weird uh you know what
I've been reading lately why the last
man I'm trying to find indie books I
want to do okay I gotta I gotta squash
that cuz cuz you're gonna I don't want
you to do it first now your comics
explained
got to be round with a poncho an indie
comics I don't know do something on sex
criminals but I think it's like every
blog and everyone has done something on
sex criminals other than the people I
actually talk to I was looking into
doing sex criminals but the style in
which I do my videos I do not think I
could get away with doing sex criminals
but a lot a lot of blurriness a title I
would think that it have a lot of like
adult oriented content and so like
that's certainly not something I bring
to my channel
oh it'll most likely be one of my
highest performing videos because it
says sex criminals it'll probably have
like everyone drops off after the first
minute they're like oh it's an indie
book when you're like we're gonna be
blurring out like the scenes of nudity
people like man [ __ ] that noise boobies
I think like my 5th most viewed video is
called on Starfire sexuality and it's
got like a picture of Starfire's
tits in the thumbnail yeah I'm not gonna
lie fast when we were kind of like
researching we wanted to bring into the
weekly poll that's the first video of
yours I watched let's see what else you
can do and then and then I immediately
went to all your video game videos and I
was like well he does video game history
haven't done that in like a year I know
I love that that comment you put on the
WatchMojo I think about that I haven't
done this where did you even get this
it's like really just kept scrolling
going
what's so what did he do like a year ago
people just keep posting up about boobs
and about PewDiePie and I don't
understand why PewDiePie is because it
was on South Park boobs is because it's
boobs oh I didn't know PewDiePie was on
South Park at least they're not talking
about like PewDiePie boobs which is is
on the comic story in play and I am
trying to give its Rob to do it I want
to see I want to see a Marvel Comics
explained version of it of what which is
Scott Snyder's witches
huh it's really good I'm still never
actually like sent down a Red Dead like
I just got my hands on Sagar
wasn't there like a Sabrina comic a few
months ago I did a joking read of an
Archie comic which you can find on the
channel and I read this story it was the
story of Archie and Sabrina teaming up
and the entire Archie crew gets turned
into animals and it's all because of
Sabrina's cat Salem so what ends up
happening is they have to team up with
Salem to go find Sabrina to reverse the
spell and like Archie I think it's like
a dog and like what's-his-name the guy
with the hat Jughead he's like a giraffe
it was so weird
see I didn't find out that Sabrina was a
comic until well after the show had
finished and then I read the comic was
like this is not like the TV show I kind
of people portrayed yes people are
putting like all these variations of
PewDiePie and boobs in ways cutie pie
boobs explains you know let's turn this
into a pseudo Q&A while we do this cuz
we've got a run run out of our Hot Topic
so there isn't any like I said guys
we've spoken to Avenue hot topics but
the thing is like I took the last two
weeks off or I've took off the week
before that off so we were kind of like
well we can't just not do it
podcast again Plus Faust is available
which is not a normal thing so yeah we
got every songs day I have nothing to do
now say well then every Tuesday you'll
be here okay but no someone asked if we
what comic would we want to seem to be
turned into a TV show oh you know that
would be that would be some like college
girl like alright here's what happened
like the way the story would hold like
it sure would open up like it'd be like
the first episode like she's in class
she's taking a math test she's just like
freaking out like oh my god I don't know
if I can pass this and like she's
panicking and then she you know the bell
ring is that she's out of there she's
like alright then she goes and sits
under a tree and then she was like come
talk to me my little friends and like
I'm running down the tree and run up on
her she starts doing that little like
squirrels her for whatever it is you
know just starts talking to the damn
squirrels yeah would happen like like I
firmly believe like I used to work at UK
I firmly believe
that place has more squirrels than
humans we have more foxes than humans as
well really foxes used to follow me home
from school I would scare the [ __ ] out
of me did you feed them come up to you
and you can pet them that's not a pet
dog is you had that cocked in ready like
if they ask me what show I want to see
made squirrel girl doing that one
they're like several like I want to see
Clarion made into a TV show as well but
made by BBC and that would never happen
no um god I would go with I go with The
Killing Joke like I would just want to
see like a four-part miniseries like
each part of us maybe half hour long art
like that no I mean I don't need to be
like a long that's what I say like a
miniseries like the Joker would make it
funny
I want to secrecy plan trinket turned
into a show hello
so okay are we talking about like
ongoing characters or reason I'm doing
character shows um God the real answer
would be a good one yeah about them
turning Diggle on arrow into Jon Stewart
Green Lantern but I don't see that
happening I had heard about that I had
heard that rumor I think he would be
good make a great Jon Stewart Green
Lantern oh you would do a great job with
it but it would just it would destroy
the lore so much yeah that everyone was
like no but was created for the show
wasn't he yeah yeah but now he's been
put into the comics and there's jokes
about he'll oh well you know if it comes
out he'll just be named John's John
Diggle Stewart um God it turns like
ongoing characters if they were we were
gonna feature him in the TV show
I mean I'd probably want to see like
like Nightwing like Dick Grayson his
Nightwing and Blair's of them using
YouTube show about that I don't know if
you've seen it he did he was tweeting is
trying to get us to retweeted that shot
she'll blow up on its own isn't
we had any kind of like following at all
well it was amazing that show yeah
nobody want to see it like with him
based and blüdhaven is what I'd want to
see because I'd like the idea of
Nightwing heaven like his own city that
he tries to protect a city's just like a
total nightmare but I like that he had
well I guess until it was destroyed by
death or death
[ __ ] man Deathstroke but I would like to
see like his own like him in his own
City doing his own thing like trying to
be like Batman but not quite making it
like I think that's what I would like to
see see I would like to see Nightwing
show if he was sexualized on the level
that women are sexualized cuz that's the
kind kind of like the point of his
character oh my god man all this gender
equality should let me tell you you know
I don't want to hear about all right
speaking of sexuality have you ever seen
the joke thing that if they gender
swapped power girl what it would look
like no when it just look like palpable
a from the Titans know what they did was
the joke was if because obviously they
went to boob windows here it would be a
penis window but it would be just above
it so you would just see like the tip
like so peeved window really there were
a few window basically there is
underwear from Andrew Christian that
exists exactly like that
anything is that what you were in the
weekends found no when I'm going out
with friends just film something nice
are you talking underwear me to pubes is
that what you just said no it's the
window around your pubes is cut out oh
it would be the gender swap version of
Power Girl cause her boobs are a oh yeah
your pubes a pube window I don't want to
see that see but if I'm honest about the
whole Nightwing situation it's not
really about gender equality and stuff
it's just as a gay man I find Nightwing
really attractive see like I never got
in like even
we just as like a character like I think
the biggest problem the deep-sea had
like if they're gonna adapt to new TVs
into a TV show sure do the whole you
know gender equality thing but the
problem that I had was when they came
out with Nightwing they said okay he was
Robin then he broke away from Batman's
shadow then he became Nightwing but he's
still like trying to be Batman make him
his own person let him do his own thing
don't make him try to be a spinoff of
that man like give him its own real
thing and that's a real thing know for
the most part I mean it's always been an
attempt at it yeah but it's always
always at the end of the day it's always
coming back - he's trying to be like
that man well you're never gonna get
away from that though Nightwing Dick
Grayson will always live in the shadow
and I think honestly that's one of the
attempts they're making with Grayson to
finally say okay everyone loves this guy
and we can't seem to eat we can't kill
him or anything like that so let's let's
try something unique on it let's make
him a secret agent who works remember I
just love Dick Grayson as Nightwing well
I never had a problem with him living in
the shadow of Batman and Grayson I can't
[ __ ] stand I've heard so much good
stuff about Grayson that I'm kind of
wanna check it out again you know I give
it a second shot grab the first trade or
something like that but see when I was
doing all my research about Dick Grayson
like I was going through when I was
looking at like the like the origins
origins and trying to clear stuff up and
I stumbled across a comic vine thread
where somebody had asked what do people
think about the new series Grayson and
this was this was like you know it was
like you like when it just came out
people were just like this sucks
like he's not Nightwing that was
basically the complaint that everybody
had like he's not Nightwing well yeah it
ain't the same character the same
history and all know like oh now he's a
completely different character yeah like
we're just gonna do that yeah people
didn't like that but nonetheless
somebody had a really good comment where
they said bring back Samurai Jack I am a
hundred percent behind that Samurai Jack
was such an awesome show like Rolando
Jones I think did the voice of Samurai
Jack and he was amazing
TV fat that was so little talking and
show they could have changed the voice
every episode and you just would not
have noticed you'd never noticed but
Samurai Jack was a great show like
however they had a little mini male mini
film I think they came on
- networker was like half an hour long
and they actually launched the the TV
show but anyway people were asking about
the daredevil trailer have you guys seen
that yet
no I avoid trailers things I'm actually
looking forward to it's actually pretty
good um I like the direction they're
taken with kingpin they it seems like
they're making kingpin more human as
opposed to in the comics where he's just
like blargh I'm the king of crime and
Hell's Kitchen blargh and he's always
posed to be larger-than-life the large
king you know jokingly about his weight
but their largest king of crime kind of
guy you know but see like they're
turning that down like they're toning
down well I mean one you probably
couldn't get a person that could
physically be the size of the kingpin of
the comics and be able to do anything
the Midwest over here man you just go to
the nearest Golden Corral and you'll
find a dozen kingpins go there on a
Sunday man after church you see all
kinds actly Phillimore that's what it
was thank you for Maryland agents yeah I
don't know it's better going to Golden
Corral on a Sunday afternoon or going to
Walmart any day of the week it's
hilarious going to like a Golden Corral
and because I have a minute Golden
Corral forever but like we used to go
there on Sundays after church man it was
almost as bad as Ryan's like it was it
was a madhouse like you walked in there
and and there's like three things that
you see one children running around with
nobody knowing what the hell they're
doing they're just running around
screaming grabbing food and [ __ ] - it's
the old ladies that just can't move fast
enough I can get up there and they get
their scuba macaroni and cheese and they
put it on their plate and then they
shuffle over to the green beans and they
get their scooper Green is like get your
[ __ ] and put it on the plate and get the
[ __ ] out of that's how it works when you
go - oh I know you guys probably all
have a face up there in in Scotland
first but we take oh okay okay so you
guys know how it works
yeah like what I was living in San
Francisco for six months a few years ago
and you know there was like oh I guess
the stereotype of overweight Americans
isn't true you know went out the city it
was like okay in some areas
where you go look at me you forgot the
best part about coming to golden crown
on a Sunday know Rob that there's no
food there and the only food dishes is
these three largest people in the entire
building have got two plates apiece
littered with it we went to go together
the days because I have family visiting
from overseas and they wanted to see the
American buffet style so to go the crowd
and had a big sign there like fish tacos
fish tacos I'm like alright go get a
fish taco that's cool you know whatever
so I go over there not once was there a
goddamn fish taco now once it was always
empty yeah man that was that was a
[ __ ] I hated that man like a man like
I want to eat I don't want to wait on
food like I want that food to be there
it doesn't have to be the warmest food
in the world
it could be looping room that's fine
especially when you get around to like
the make it be soupy and undercooked and
taste horrible
be there what waited me out about
America was how big your buffets are
like in England they're relatively small
you know there's enough food to like put
on your plate and have a good time like
in America this like a whole ballroom
just filled with food I went to Vegas
for a trip to a Final Fantasy 14
festival I went to the Final Fantasy
think fast which you probably know about
that you play the game yeah I went to
Vegas and they have the Vegas buffets
every food in the world is just at your
disposal and it literally is the size of
a ballroom did you look back I guess no
we didn't look for a because I remember
seeing it being like I am NOT trying
that in a buffet like I've never had it
before in a buffet will not be the first
time I tried Angus no way I'm not gonna
order or something like haggis in the
sitting out for like six hours she
shoved into its own like inside yeah
let's let's trust that a dyad a you know
had a buffet isn't that the point of
buffets thank you don't like something
new without really worrying all right it
is what you already love yeah you know
you know what other thing that you
avoided every buffet the sushi this is
the same man I will wreck that sushi
like a Chinese buffet they're keeping it
right don't go to Golden Corral and
their sushi no man look you'll die you
get sushi up a face in America yes I
live like close to London lose Chinatown
here I have never seen sushi in a buffet
the real Chinese food stuff anyway okay
okay so anyway so back to the topic of
coffe topic and we get it's my curse I'm
sorry food explained that would be an
awesome thing would you should that
should because you were trying to talk
about trying to launch a secondary
channel I got a guy with the gaming
stuff you should do food explain and all
this should be is you trying out things
just like cooking things just go
someplace and try out food just so I got
this it could be anything it could be
anything staying there buying my frozen
pizza today we're gonna try to zorb
DiGiorno tomorrow's gonna be the cheddar
Bay biscuits at at Red Lobster and the
day after that we're gonna go to
Chinatown and I'm gonna eat cat video
Bay biscuits like nothing would get done
I will just be like give me one more
like after this biscuit we'll start
talking about it biscuit will give those
things are so good but they're so
terrible for you then it's an awesome
idea just like like food explained would
you watch Rob just eat food and say like
yeah this cheeseburger at Wendy's was
amazing no I think it'd be fun to like
cook food in just comics boobs boobs we
just need to add in butts and movies and
then we have a full pentagram who's got
an amazing but I know spice has a real
amazing I was about to say I got a weird
feeling if we go into the butts region
the Preferences will be completely
different from all okay I'm not gonna
talk about coming of a character buds
because that comes out creepy oh you
guys know that's a really amazing but
like rogue I think I get away because my
buddy hasn't aged since I was like 16 so
when I did it's like when I first went
to your channel like like Benny was like
hey man like you should check out super
effective and I was like okay and so
like what your channel and checked it
out and I'm like this guy's like 14
years old mid-20s age explain I watching
one of your older videos paused and like
you had lost some weight by going to the
gym and everyone's like bit Foust gets
sickly when you go to the gym I even got
one message cuz I've been open about
like I mentioned once in one of my AMAs
like I used to have an eating disorder
and so message me like my paragraphs
about don't give him don't go back to
your regimen I broke both my ankles in
the military myself so I tried like I
got out of here at half ago now and I
tried to maintain the weight loss but
without running or doing anything like
elliptical or crap because like that's
just impossible
so given in lemon shoots like swimming I
can put there's nowhere to swim around
here because it's Colorado it's all ice
cold there's no beaches so so like I'm
trying to like CrossFit with like
push-ups and crap like it just wasn't
I've seen those crawfish championship
man like those CrossFit tournaments
those are freaking nuts but now we got
food comics movie now we have done
movies yet food comics boobs butts and
Jim put that in the time like this this
this was so much about having fun here
each time Foust has been on here we
never been on topic it's my cus you know
interesting curse it could be a lot
worse yeah I don't think it's a bad I
don't think it's a curse at all like I
think it's pretty awesome
but um ya know anyway so so back onto
the topic of comics no with daredevil
I'd like what they're doing like at
least what they seem to be doing with
the Netflix series
I like kingpin who's more real-world
which is what they're going for with all
their Marvel Cinematic Universe so
they're going for like more real-world
depictions of comic book characters
you're not gonna find a man who's gonna
be 7 feet tall and 600 pounds and if you
did then that guy's a freakin Hoss but
you know the the Vincent D'Onofrio more
toned-down darker sinister yes I'm a
little bit human but I'm also got like a
really screwed-up dark side kind of
character I think it's cool
what they're gonna do with Matt Murdock
I don't know it kind of depends but in
truth and I'll be honest with you gosh
it wouldn't surprise me if this happens
I could see kingpin completely out
shining daredevil in his own series
people are just like oh my god gang make
a kingpin series no no no I'm not
talking on a kingpins solo series I'm
saying outshining Deadpool in there
daredevil in the daredevil series like
people are gonna watch the show and be
like oh my god like kingpin is the best
part of this show as opposed to
daredevil himself but oh yeah so kind of
like the Dark Knight Returns where Joker
was how everyone loves him more ya know
of course we're not gonna make a kingpin
so why would they make a kingpin solo
series will be the purpose behind that I
don't know it could be The Sopranos
imagine the kingpin solo series set up
like The Sopranos well as long as the
Ducks come back at the end that's fun so
I don't wanna watch the kingpin eating
in the show cut to an end it's an iron
fist supposed to come out this year as
well I think all the Netflix tours are
supposed to come out this year like I'm
at age iron fist Jessica Jones and
daredevil I think they're spaced out so
they don't conflict with the release of
age of Ultron yeah each other and Ant
Man but I don't think Marvel is really
in truth and I'm I'll be honest with you
guys I don't think Marvel's putting a
whole lot of stock behind a men I think
they're kind of like I think it works
out but I think that's kind of like if
it doesn't well you know they're just
[ __ ] and it's not worried about you
know what I think they're doing is
they're good treating regarding to the
galaxy I mean yeah they hyped
like they're doing with ant-man but you
saw more guardians of the galaxy after
it came out and it sold like crazy then
you saw two comic series they popped up
everywhere they were all over the place
you know well let's see that's the thing
like like ant-man solo series ant-man
number one where Scott Lang is like
trying to get a job and stuff like that
like it's just not selling like people
just don't really care I mean number one
debuted at like number nine or ten on
the charts or something like that so it
just wasn't like people just didn't
really care and and the reason for that
is because no one really cares about
Scott Lang people think of ant-man they
think I'm Hank Pym and that's really
yeah so I just to comment didn't nothing
there tie my hands on I said you guys
watch and I explained dramatically and
the tentacles came out of nowhere
cartoon porn explained that's disgusting
the sections on yah we owe the hardcore
yeah Lee specifically we're gonna make
that channel cartoon porn explain okay
Jessica Jones comes out later this year
the other ones come out next year okay
I'll do I'll do all the cat girls post
you can do the Yahweh I'll do the cat
girls I have no idea what's going on
right now we're talking cartoon porn now
oh well in that case I'll just read the
comments it's all gonna reflect itself
in a minute I want to know like like you
know I wish that I could make like a
clone of myself and just like go visit
our viewers like while we're talking in
the podcast cuz I want to I want to know
what they're doing like like somebody
says something funny and they're just
like okay like what should I say like
everything explained and like that
comment feel how Rob comes up with
topics explain I'm going back to the TV
show so I'll be interested to see how
they do the Iron Fist show because
there's like rumors floating around but
they're doing it like a 70s martial arts
movie which I really hope you
maybe do it like come how did anybody
see compound yes man gofer trucks yes
all rush hour if they do it like rush
hour we'll be really happy
oh yeah oh wait a minute Kung Pao no I
was thinking of Kung Fu Hustle is what I
was thinking of he's like a baby
Emma Frost boobs explained if you made
that be your biggest video I'm telling
it right would be Emma Frost boobs
explained like just explain how our
boobs have changed in size over the
years you know what can I do that you
know what [ __ ] it we're gonna do that
one day like we do that tomorrow
well why is this a meme let me explain
boobs like we're gonna explain Emma
Frost breasts over the course of her
continuity in Marvel Comics comics we
are talking comics Emma Frost boobs are
an important comic book topic they are
an important thing Robb's cleans like I
do for your april 1st video because I
gotta cover Secret Wars a convergence
just cover like the breasts of comic
book characters and Marvel Comics DC
Comics stars breasts explained now that
we're coming to the end of our usual
time sync and every like that so let's
let's talk about a movie real quick cuz
anybody seen chappie yet no is it good
okay alright then so then we discussed a
movie so power girls boobs explained you
can explain now wonder how she's never
had a symbol I look let me ask you this
okay hold on before we go fast how do
you feel about Power Girl putting the
super hand symbol over that and that
becoming her new symbol I hate it it was
Power Girl like you can't just uh
you can't outright declare her a member
of the super family like that no she's
like yeah she's Kryptonian but she's not
a member of the super family know it
like and she never will be I give it
like three years maximum
well you know it's story wise it's cool
I liked the moment which they did that
then they changed her costume to reflect
that and I was like now yeah yeah I give
it three years there'll be another at
Club well no the only lasted one year
last time with her current costume where
it was like all white with the big P
right here
his chain and they pulled that away
because everyone was complaining
yeah they recovered her boobs again guys
some persons gray the blue bores like
this like have a competition like whose
boobs are better that's a great idea for
a show like alright we're so we're gonna
decide whose boobs better here's your
competition whose butts are better
here's competition awesome idea like
boobs vs. buns
who's got stronger powers like it any
word say this you don't get creepy so to
be like whose boobs are better whose
butts are better they'd be like whose
powers are better who's more
telepathically capable who's got the
better bra size you know what we're
gonna do that you know why not
you know what you know why not [ __ ] it
at this point I can just kind of throw
whatever I could just then you can call
it you can call it boobs and battles
boobs or probably beat your best
performing show oh yeah
battle of the boobs if you just compared
boobs and just let the audience decide
here's these boobs they are at a cup
they are no just slightly nude pictures
of them they aren't real vision of boobs
like punching each other like boxing
cups and all of that note guys thank you
for joining us for another weird episode
of the weekly video there's a Japanese
anime that I watched where they did have
boob battles like that I don't
it was it wasn't actually porn it was
just battling boobs no it came it came
out of Japan so you know like I saw this
mean it was like 91 percent of the
weirdest [ __ ] comes out of Japan klopott
the plot behind it was that was in a
feudal age of Japan in which boobs were
considered like the most glorified thing
in the world so women battled with boob
techniques and when they won they would
absorb the boobs of other women so their
boobs would get bigger and other girls
would go flat-chested no well the next
season of Sailor Moon sounds great
alright guys I think I think we should
edit here because we're just totally off
kilter we'll be back next week if we
have a topic
we've acted normal otherwise it's been
another episode of the weird pull um I'm
dubbing it whenever we do these videos
it's got to be the weird pull from now
on so people know what they're getting
into when they come into this podcast so
dangerous world zone topic it's the
weird pull and that's the one that pass
is always on the weird not my fault if
it was Robin would be debating clowns
just researching venom we'd probably be
talking venom at spider-man Baus is here
boob battles we're gonna bounce off here
hi you guys ever great I'm comic story
and that is comics explain that is it's
super effective go check out all the
channels it make sure you go check out
our website though weekly pulled on Nets
where you can chat with us all on the
forums Foust will eventually start
actually responding to his forum
eventually but you can chat with us all
over there follow us on Twitter at the
weekly poll and very soon we will be
launching our hitbox channel which is
where the podcasts will be moving to so
keep your ears to the ground and follow
us all on Twitter or our channel so you
know when that happens yeah we will see
you guys next time and any other setups
like no I guess the only thing I'll say
before we bring this podcast to an end
is that will say that the thing that
Nick Terry said the Thor is that Thor's
not actually the son of Odin catch you
guys later